[Musik]
willkommen liebe hörerinnen liebe hörer
am 10 juli hätte marcel proust seinen
geburtstag gefeiert und solche jubiläen
bieten immer wieder anlass zu neuen
publikationen zu neuausgaben
neuübersetzung und biografien und
natürlich fragt man sich auch gern was
solche langen verblichenen autoren uns
heute eigentlich noch zu sagen haben
im fall der recherche wie der kenner
bruce hauptwerk nennt kommt dazu dass
viele so ungefähr wissen was drin steht
aber kaum jemand hat es vollständig
gelesen ich weiß nicht wie es dir geht
lieber fridtjof aber viel mehr als die
stichworte madeleine und lindenblütentee
kann ich dazu nicht beitragen
bei mir sind es nicht so sehr
stichwörter als vielmehr ein
schreckliches erlebnis was mich mit der
recherche verbindet ich habe vor vielen
jahren mal versucht den ersten band
zumindest im urlaub zu lesen hat ihn
eingepackt habe auf dem hinweg bei
freunden station gemacht zusammen mit
meinem kleinen sohn mit dem ich
unterwegs war unterlag so ein kursbuch
um kinder haben keine kinder haben war
das thema und ich habe mich in einem
essay fest gelesen in dem ich auf die
frage stieß haben sie schon mal versucht
post zu lesen wenn kinder dabei sind
ich dachte das wollen wir doch erst mal
sehen und wild entschlossen weiter in
den urlaub gefahren und drei seiten weit
gekommen in diesem buch also dunkles
kapitel aber große hoffnung dass sich
jetzt zum 150 geburtstag in all dem was
drum herum über proust gesagt
geschrieben zu lesen sein wird haben
dass sich das ändert wenn man das sich
auch durch das gespräch an hat was wir
gleich führen wir haben danach können
sie sich liebe hörerinnen und hörer
freuen auf drei fragen die wir diesmal
der frisch gekürten bachmann
preisträgerin nawar ibrahimi gestellt
haben
aber davor machen wir es uns als podcast
gastgeber so einfach wie wir es uns
gerne mal machen und verlassen und beim
gespräch über proust ganz auf die
expertise unseres kollegen und literatur
chefs andreas
aus der sollte uns gesagt momentan gar
nichts anderes liest als bücher von und
über marcel pust schön dass sie sich
trotz dieser ausufernden lektüre zeit
für uns nehmen lieber platz aus ich muss
zugeben lieber küchemann dass meine
brust lektüre mit der rezension die
jetzt kürzlichen faz erschienen ist
erstmal wieder abgeschlossen ist zwei
wochen reichen dann auch irgendwann um
sich wieder tolle post reinzuwachsen bis
sich das dritte mal die recherche
komplett lesen werde wird wahrscheinlich
doch noch ein paar jahre dauern
das wollten wir jetzt eigentlich sogar
als erstes wissen haben sie die
recherche die suche nach der verlorenen
zeit jemals so richtig vollständig
gelesen und wenn ja war das jetzt mehr
pflicht oder war das mehr kühe bei ihnen
das war tatsächlich jeweils für wobei
sie einmal einen pflicht anlass hatte
aber sich dann zu einer wunderbaren kühe
entwickelte ich habe die recherchen
etappen gelesen beim ersten mal
ich habe genau wie herr küche man zuerst
mal einen band mit den urlaub genommen
das war noch sizilien nach taormina und
den habe ich zwar immerhin ausgelesen
damals aber ich hatte irgendwie
zurückgekehrt dann nicht den ansporn
weiter zu lesen das ist nun mittlerweile
allerdings auch an die zwanzig jahre her
und dann habe ich irgendwann dann
wiederum gesagt gut den ersten band hast
du gelesen kaum noch erinnerungen daran
ließ sie noch mal und dann war ich so
fasziniert davon dass ich über einen
zeitraum von ich schätze mal so drei
oder vier monaten die sieben bände
gelesen habe und dann gab es einen
vortrag um den mann mit bart bei einer
tagung der proust gesellschaft in der
ich zwar nicht mitglied bin der ich aber
sehr sympathisch gegenüberstehe
und dafür gab es natürlich die
verpflichtung noch mal so zu gucken
es ging ums essen bei proust und da habe
ich einfach alle bände noch mal mit den
urlaub genommen auf eine griechische
insel und diesmal wusste ich ja worin
das problem besteht man muss einfach
dranbleiben und ich habe mir einfach
vorgenommen du liest jeden tag einen
band proust und nach sieben tagen war
ich durch natürlich habe ich da nichts
anderes getan außer bis war einmal ins
meer zu gehen und post zu lesen
aber das war eine tolle erfahrung und
deshalb viel mehr spaß gemacht als es
verteilte lesen beim ersten mal das ist
also der erste tipp den wir schon mal
festhalten müssen dran bleiben und jeden
tag ein
ja ja das ist natürlich ambitioniert man
muss seine sonstigen urlaubs interessen
weitgehend zurückstellen und ich bin
immer noch nicht ganz sicher ob meine
frau überglücklich über diese woche
gewesen ist aber gottlob schloss sich ja
noch eine zweite woche daran an
in der ich dann andere dinge lesen
konnte die deutlich entspannter und auch
weniger zeitintensiv waren so gesehen
hoffe ich mal sie ist auch noch ein
bisschen auf meine auf ihre kosten mit
mir gegolten
dann war auch der urlaub eine ganz
eigene suche nach der verlorenen zeit
sozusagen
was erwarten uns denn an neue ausgaben
oder neuen blicken auf die suche nach
der verlorenen zeit neue blicke auf die
suche nach der verlorenen zeit gar nicht
so wahnsinnig intensive es gibt eine
fülle an büchern in deutschland ich habe
sicherlich gar nicht mal alle
wahrgenommen die in diesem jahr oder
sagen wir den letzten monat neu
herausgekommen sind und die meisten
davon beschäftigen sich weniger mit dem
hauptwerk mit diesem siebenbändigen
romanzyklus als mit der person pro
selbst dass dabei natürlich immer wieder
der blick auf das was er geschrieben hat
fällt ist unvermeidlich denn es gibt
kaum ein buch was dermaßen intensiv mit
der persönlichkeit und dem leben ihres
seines autors verbunden ist
andererseits hat bewusst sich immer
dagegen verwahrt dass man das so einfach
gleichsetzt und dementsprechend ist eine
rein geografische lektüre dieses buchs
dann auch nicht besonders zielführend
es ist trotzdem interessant viel über
proust zu erfahren
michael kleeberg hat einmal gesagt oder
respektive jetzt erst kürzlich
geschrieben und man könnte sich ja kaum
ein langweiliges leben vorstellen als
das von marcel proust in gewisser weise
hat er recht weil brucia dafür
berüchtigt ist dass er gerade in den
letzten jahren seines lebens so gut wie
nie mehr ausgegangen ist alle seine
energie die weiß nicht mehr
gesundheitsbedingt so riesig groß dabei
schwer asthmakranken ist das was ihm
blieb an energie hat er aufs schreiben
verwendet und dementsprechend hat der
nicht mehr viel erlebt andererseits hat
post sich immer wieder von freunden
unglaublich viel erzählen lassen über
das was in paris vor geht das überhaupt
in der feinen gesellschaft geschieht
oder in den künsten
so gesehen war der mit der welt schon
sehr sehr eng verbunden und das wiederum
erklärt zu bekommen aus briefwechseln
aus schilderungen von freundschaften aus
analysen von bruce persönlichkeit selbst
das ist schon sehr sehr faszinierend und
da gibt es ein paar bücher die ich mit
ausgesprochenem vergnügen gelesen habe
bevor wir jetzt zu diesen biographien
briefwechseln augenzeugen berichten und
so weiter kommen eine frage hätte ich ja
doch also es gibt eben von bruce dieses
monumentalwerk die suche sieben bände
hat der mann in seinem leben sonst
nichts geschrieben was kann man denn
neben der recherche vielleicht noch
entdecken und was nutzt das vielleicht
sogar zum einstieg für leute die
bisschen eingeschüchtert sind da gleich
das ganze zu nehmen ehrlich gesprochen
nicht wirklich denn das problem ist dass
ihre schacht ein solitär auch im leben
von proust ist nicht dass er nichts
anderes geschrieben hätte er hat
begonnen als mit 20 jähriger mit einem
jahr noch stark romantisierend
verfassten band namens freuden und tage
das sind kleine fiktive texte sehr
elegant sehr fern dass jäckle artig
formuliert aber das hat vom anspruch her
überhaupt nichts mit dem später und werk
zu tun und prost war selber auch später
nicht mehr unglaublich glücklich mit
dieser publikation die sich nebenbei
auch inserate verkauft hat also als er
starb waren immer noch wer weiß wie
viele exemplare in seinem besitz oder
dem des verlegers danach hat er mehrere
größere roman projekte begonnen john
terry ist das berühmteste auch noch im
neunzehnten jahrhundert oder contra
sandberg ungefähr um 1907 1908 gewonnen
und dann auch abgebrochen das waren
jeweils tatsächlich vorstufen zu dem was
später die recherche werden sollte man
merkt da schon dieselbe erzähler haltung
einer ähnlichen blick auf die welt aber
es eben jeweils in diesen zehn
jahresabstand nicht mit diesem vorhaben
ein ganzes leben zu liberalisieren zu
rande gekommen und hat daneben ein
drittes mal begonnen
und das ist es dann auch darüber ist er
gestorben also mehr gibt es nicht von
post allerdings ist jetzt bei suhrkamp
ein band heraus gekommen der vor zwei
jahren in frankreich große
aufmerksamkeit gefunden nämlich mit
frühen erzählungen die bislang noch
nicht publiziert waren weil die
manuskripte in der hand eines bekannten
post verlegers gewesen sind und der hat
sie zwar ausgewertet für seine
publikationen über den mann aber sie
selber nie veröffentlicht und das ist
dann geschehen da merkt man dann den weg
von proust von diesen frühen versuchen
hin zur recherche dass es interessant
und auch
und zu lesen und die deutsche
übersetzung ist durchaus geglückt ist
ein zauberhaft schön gemachter band und
trotzdem würde ich behaupten dass wer
denkt dass man sich damit den weg zur
recherche ebnet dann liegt man falsch
denn das ist etwas ganz anderes 20
seiten kleine erzählungen zu lesen oder
mit dem band den mann aufschlägt zu
wissen gut jetzt liegen knappe
zweieinhalb bis 3000 seiten je nach
deutsche ausgabe vor mir und zugegebener
weise erst das ganze macht den richtig
großen reiz aus in teilen ist es wie
gesagt nicht so faszinierend das risiko
des abbruchs groß kommen wir mal zu
ihrer monumentalen lektüre im rahmen des
jubiläums erscheinen ja jetzt eine ganze
reihe biografischer betrachtung und was
lohnt sich davon und vor allem steht da
irgendwas drin was wir bisher noch nicht
wussten
man muss vorausschicken das ist eine
viel weniger monumentale lektüre gewesen
als die lektüre von bruce selbst also im
endeffekt alles sehr entspannt was man
über proust ließ der vielleicht außer
der großen biografie von jeeves ag die
auf 1300 seiten hat also einen
eklatanten leser aufwand erfordert ist
alles was man über proust liest viel
simpler zugänglich und schneller gelesen
als brust selbst aber natürlich lohnt
das teilweise immens und es gibt ein
ganz erstaunliches buch und das ist von
lothar müller einem früheren kollegen
von der süddeutschen zeitung
mittlerweile im ruhestand und der hat
wenn man seinen bemerkungen im buch
glauben darf sich wohl erst während der
pandemie monate im letzten jahr
entschlossen sich dem thema brust und
die medizin zuzuwenden
das ist nichts was bislang unbekannt
wäre ärzte spielen eine ganz wichtige
rolle in der recherche und natürlich
auch in poes leben gerade weil er so
schwer krank war
aber es hat noch nie jemand sich
systematisch angeschaut wie es sich mit
dem verhältnis von pos zu seinem vater
adrian trust iv erhält ein sehr
bedeutender mediziner der dritten
republik in frankreich vor allem deshalb
wichtig weil er der haupt zuständige für
die solchen unterdrückung war und das
ist natürlich zur zeit super aktuell
damals ging es um die cholera jetzt geht
es um corona aber adrian trust hat sich
damals ähnliche gedanken gemacht wie wir
es heute tun wie müssen wir uns
abschotten damit so ein krankheitskeime
nicht ins land rein kommt und er hat
wahnsinnig viel publiziert sammelbände
fachaufsätze und das alles ist natürlich
bislang schon mal gelesen worden aber
noch nicht
systematisch wie lothar müller ist tot
im verhältnis zu dem was sein sohn
geschrieben hat und es ist gar kein
biografisches buchmann erfährt sehr
wenig über die psychologische seite über
die jeweiligen sympathien und
antipathien von vater und sohn als
vielmehr ein vergleich von beide
argumentationen und schreibweise und das
faszinierende daran ist dass man am ende
gar nicht mal weiß ist jetzt eigentlich
posten etwas mehr beeinflusst von der
art des wirklichkeit zugangs seines
vaters oder hat mich vielleicht auch der
sohn selber wiederum den vater ganz
stark geprägt denn lothar müller hat
gute gründe dafür festzustellen dass
wahrscheinlich marcel proust einige
texte seines vaters zumindest mit
angeregt oder regiert hat weil einfach
formulierungen drin sind die so trust
typisch sind dass man sie eigentlich bei
jemand anderem selbst wenn es der vater
ist nicht erwarten dürfte und das ist
ein großes lesevergnügen weil es
wirklich noch mal ein neues licht auf
bestimmte passagen in der recherche
wirft und weil es auch nebenbei ganz
exzellent und elegant geschrieben ist
das ganze hat 200 seiten die sind
zugegebener weise nicht besonders groß
gedruckt da hat man schon was dran zu
lesen aber es ist gerade auch unter dem
aspekt der aktualität mit der
seuchenbekämpfung ein wirklich
faszinierend zu lesendes buch denn man
erfährt auch kulturgeschichtliche
einiges über das was adrian post getan
hat sind gerade proust typische
formulierung während was wären denn so
prost typische formulierungen des königs
beispiel was müller nimmt und das ist
vielleicht der einzige vorwurf den man
dem buch überhaupt machen kann dass er
ein bisschen zu selten adrian probst im
original also nicht im original als text
zitiert
müller beschreibt mehr wie er schreibt
aber es gibt eine ganz wunderbare sache
eine rede die adrianos kurz vor seinem
tod im jahr 1903 in seiner geburtsstadt
gehalten hat und wohl zu schülern
gesprochen hat über die wichtigkeit von
gesundheitsvorsorge und hygiene und da
macht er einen schlenker zu dem kleinen
flüsschen was durch diesen ort heißt der
das ist dann im werk seines sohns zu den
berühmten ort konkret geworden sind
kleinen flüsschen was dadurch fließt und
saatgut unter den aspekten die wir heute
bei der gesundheitsvorsorge beachten
müssen müssen wir endlich diesen fluss
begradigen und dafür sorgen dass es da
irgendwie ordentlich durchfließt damit
kein stehendes wasser ist damit ich da
keine bakterien entwickeln aber
andererseits wenn man sich jetzt
vorstellen wie ich diesen fluss als kind
kennengelernt
nicht da entlang gelaufen bin mir die
seerosen angesehen habe dieses herrliche
murmeln des kleinen bächleins diese ruhe
diese entspannung diese völlige
widerstand der natur gegen die gegen die
zivilisation und gegen die moderne
da ist es irgendwo auch wieder schade
dass wir diesen fluss begradigen werden
und das alles für stören lassen
und das ist etwas was man in großes werk
also so bruce war immer wieder findet
diese ambivalenz des blicks auf die
moderne liegt die dadurch entsteht dass
er bei all dem nachtrauert was in
gewisser weise durch die moderne
verschwindet und gerade die seerosen
gerade die beschreibung dieses flüssigen
sind so prominent auch in der recherche
vertreten dass man die war zu dem
zeitpunkt nicht geschrieben also noch
nicht mal begonnen dass man sagen muss
dann ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder ein
keim zu diesem buch vermutlich in dieser
rede des vaters und der mann
wahrscheinlich annehmen darf dass der so
zumindest mit dran geschrieben hat das
klingt toll und es klingt so als ob man
sich dann auch zwischen also den
äußerungen dem was man an texten des
vaters kennt und denen des sohnes aber
auch zwischen den einzelnen edition
schritten oder fahnen notiz schritten
veränderungs schritten des sohnes ganz
schön verlaufen könnte also mit der
frage wie entwickeln sich die wie
entwickeln sich die gedanken dann weiter
beim wiederlesen des geschriebenen bei
der angesichts der frage ob das jetzt
wirklich so in druck gehen soll
was bewegt sich da im text das ist
natürlich dann schon eine sehr
spezialist ische betrachtungsweise also
wenn man sich dermaßen intensiv auf die
exegese von proust einlassen will dass
man wirklich mehrere ausgaben vorstufen
und sowas nebeneinanderliegen hat um das
zu vergleichen dann sollte man schon
sehr überzeugt brust jana sein mir macht
das einen heidenspaß das ist für mich
ganz klar der wichtigste literarische
autorin meiner leser biografie weil
selbst wenn ich ihn nicht komplett jetzt
so schnell noch mal lese ich immer
wieder alle paar wochen in irgendeinen
brust band rein blätter um bestimmte
szenen nachzusehen oder mich einfach mal
ganz kurz blendend zu amüsieren oder auf
allerhöchstem literarischen niveau
unterhalten zu lassen
diese vergleichs arbeit dagegen die
erfordert eben tatsächlich eine menge
mühe und auch eine menge zeit darum hat
es wirklich nur dann reiz wenn man sich
ganz diesem autor verschreibt es kann
beruflich leider gottes nicht mal aber
ich bin sehr glücklich über so zwei
wochen wie die letzten beiden wo ich das
endlich nochmal in exzessivem maße tun
konnte als es die letzten monate der
fall gewesen ist
und wie gesagt hat man ihn einmal lieb
gewonnen dann wird man immer mehr über
ihn wissen wollen das erklärt auch warum
so viele bücher über ihn erscheinen
es gibt ein publikum für bruce es gibt
gerade in deutschland ein publikum für
proust deutschland war überhaupt ein
land was ich sehr früh für ihn
interessiert hat die erste übersetzung
kam kurz nach seinem toten und seit 24
heraus und ernst robert curtius der
wirklich beste organist des frühen
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts war jemand der
das lob von bruce noch schon zu dessen
lebzeiten gesungen hat und dass man
beispielsweise dessen studie über marcel
proust die 1925 erschien also drei jahre
nach dem tod jetzt in einer neuausgabe
lesen kann ist ein großes glück denn das
ist etwas von dem man durch die auch
alle wussten dass es existiert aber es
war einfach seit vielen vielen jahren
nicht mehr greifbar und dieses frühe
buch über proust gehört zum allerbesten
was überhaupt seitdem über ihn
geschrieben worden ist die hellsicht von
von kurt jooss unfassbar
der kannte nicht mal die ganze recherche
als er seine studie über bewusst schrieb
aber er hat dinge vorausgesehen die
beispielsweise im letzten band
erscheinen würden dieses buchs also das
war auch jemand der genau wie bruce
dachte und hätten die mehr kontakt
miteinander gab hätte man auch denken
können dass boost an diesen texten
mitgeschrieben hat danach wollte ich
ehrlich gesagt auch gerade fragen nach
kurzschluss der ja so ein bisschen
tatsächlich post eigentlich für
deutschland entdeckt hat kann man glaube
ich sagen was hat er für ein bild dieses
schriftstellers gezeichnet und
unterscheidet sich das irgendwie von dem
wie wir brust heute sehen oder ist das
ist ja eigentlich nur nein es ist ein
positivistischer das bild was natürlich
aus der zeit heraus erklärlich ist
erstmal ist es jemand der im prost
offensichtlich einen autor fand der
ziemlich genau dieselben französischen
autoren liebte wie kurt jooss selbst dh
victor hugo balzac all die leute die
post auch vergöttert hat die hat auch
kurz selbstverständlich großartig
gefunden und fühlt es sich da um ganz
wunderbar aufgehoben lektüre von proust
weil er immer wieder diese älteren
spuren der großen französischen
tradition des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
eben auch im presswerk wand und
gleichzeitig hat er nie die these
vertreten dass bruce ein klassischer
autor sei
sondern er sagt er macht etwas ganz
anderes daraus mit proust beginnt etwas
völlig neues und das ist genau das wie
die heute natürlich immer noch auf
proust geblickt wird wobei der kampf
darum nicht entschieden ist ob man
postet als letzten großen autor des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts auch das thema
des themas wegen betrachten soll
oder als den beginn der moderne am
zwanzigsten jahrhundert ich neige er dem
letzteren zu weil die art der
schreibweise die post betreibt sich
signifikant von seinen vorläufern
unterscheidet und einfach soviel
angeregt hat im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
dass ich ihn vielmehr hierhin stecken
möchte als sozusagen als höhepunkt des
neunzehnten besser anfangen als ende und
das ist bei kommt dann erst das da muss
ich jetzt doch mal nach bohren dass das
psychologisch dichte beschreiben seiner
selbst und natürlich steckt im erzähler
der recherche ganz viel von marcel
proust selbst dafür muss man nur die
großen briefausgaben lesen oder sowas
und zugucken wie viel da eingeflossen
ist und die absolute gnadenlosigkeit im
betrachten seiner selbst und der welt um
sich herum
es hat nach jedem band der neu
erschienen von proust immer wieder ärger
gegeben mit bekannten mit freunden oder
so was die sich darin porträtiert fanden
teilweise zutreffend teilweise nicht
zutreffend aber man hat es von anfang an
als schlüsselroman gelesen und das ist
einerseits eine zulässige lektüre weil
eben so viel rein gegangen ist und
andererseits trotzdem keine faire
lektüre weil brust sich schon bemüht hat
ganz viele dinge zusammenzubringen und
diese sagen wir mal montage form die
etwa betreibt und gleichzeitig auch die
über unglaublich lange satz perioden
gehende innere selbstbefragung des
erzählers der das ganze buch nur
schreibt um seinen weg zum
bücherschreiben letztlich zu
legitimieren
das ist etwas was es so in der in dieser
intensität soweit ich es sehe nicht
gegeben hat natürlich schrieb zur selben
zeit thomas mann ähnlich lange
satzstrukturen aber das war eben doch
noch ein viel realistischeres erzählen
als äußerliches erzählen
im betreff auf die psychologie der
figuren als es bei proust der fall ist
es eine innere studie von er eigentlich
der menschheit weil man sich darin immer
wieder findet das würde ich sagen ist
genau das was dann mit dem inneren
monolog den joyce kultiviert hat oder
viele andere moderne autoren die nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg gerade in amerika
gekommen sind bis hin würde ich
behaupten zur grenzenlosen groteske und
fantastik von thomas prinz schon wie
proust aber diesen univer
sein blick auf sozusagen alle welt
phänomene verdankt das ist für mich
sicherlich das prägendste was ich
überhaupt an einflüssen in der literatur
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
was nicht heißt dass es nicht andere
sehr einflussreiche autoren gab aber ich
glaube von der breite der wirkung ist
unerreicht diese frühe faszination
hierzulande für ihn die wirklich noch
mal interessieren wie lässt sich die
erklären
in diesem fall tatsächlich nur über die
person von kurt jooss denn prost wurde
nicht zu lebzeiten übersetzt der erste
band der recherche münster 13 erschien
das war unmittelbar vor dem ersten
weltkrieg
und man muss zugeben dass der erste
weltkrieg nicht unbedingt dazu geeignet
war die begeisterung der deutschen für
französische literatur zu vermehren
genau wie steht auch nicht der fall war
prost war jemand der die deutsche
literatur sehr geschätzt hat obwohl er
immer behauptete er könne gar nicht gut
deutsch lesen
aber er muss es teilweise getan haben
und dementsprechend war prost auch in
kriegszeiten ein etwas verschiedener
autor in seinen eigenen kreisen war als
zu deutschfreundlich galt das ist nun
keine politische komponente die
wesentlich ist für das werk aber die
sehr interessantes betrifft einiger
figuren die beispielsweise biografisch
deutsche hintergründe haben und ähnliche
dinge und kurz muss der nun sich nach
dem ersten weltkrieg als mittler
verstand der unbedingt diese entstandene
feindschaft über den ersten weltkrieg
zumindest kulturell vermindern wollte
ist auf die suche gegangen nach autoren
die dafür tauchten und ist auf brust
gestoßen das war nicht besonders schwer
denn hat 1919 den wichtigsten
französischen literaturpreis prix
goncourt bekommen für den zweiten band
der recherche das heißt wer auch immer
sich für romanistik interessiert in der
damaligen zeit der sollte wenn er den
französische romanistik lehrte unbedingt
gelesen haben das hat nicht nur kurz los
getan aber kurz hus bei derjenige der so
glaube ich zumindest verstanden hat und
den reiz darin und vor allem was ganz
neuartige erkannt hat was auch in
frankreich überhaupt nicht erkannt
worden ist und das hat wiederum proust
unglaublich charmiert kurs hat einen
kurzen briefwechsel mit ihm unterhalten
genug zeit war nicht weil 1922 starb
aber es muss begeistert gewesen sein
über diese reaktion und fühlte sich
offensichtlich von co ceos blendend
verstanden und war natürlich auch noch
besonders angetan davon dass jemand im
ausland sich für diese französische
literatur begeistert denn wie gesagt
übersetzt war zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
nicht und das hat auf
die schule gemacht in der deutschen
romanistik ich bin kein experte für die
genaue rezeption von post in den 20er
jahren
aber wenn man bedenkt dass walter
benjamin zu seinen ersten übersetzung
gehört zusammen mit franz hessel dann
sieht man dass die besten köpfe die in
diesem land kulturbetrieben haben sich
für prost interessiert und auch
begeistert haben ich würde ja gerne noch
mal fragen
sie haben ja schon so ein bisschen
angedeutet die recherche ist eigentlich
ein roman der gut in diese zeit passt
soll man das heute noch lesen warum soll
man das nachlesen und in welcher
übersetzung soll man es lesen das letzte
ist eine ist die besonders schwierige
frage darum fange ich da mal mit an es
ist keine frage dass die bruce rezeption
in deutschland geprägt ist von einer
übersetzerin die sich der recherchen den
50er jahren angenommen hat eine
schülerin von ernst robert curtius eva
reichl mertens die hat zum ersten mal
die recherche komplett ins deutsche
gebracht das war die fassung die bei
suhrkamp für jahrzehnte die einzige war
die ist ein bisschen überarbeitet worden
von dem schweizer post experten lucius
keller der hat ein bisschen geglättet
und ein paar umständlichkeiten entfernt
und ein paar übersetzungsfehler
revidiert und ein paar
übersetzungsfehler revisionen später
wieder revidiert in späteren auflagen
weil dann plötzlich doch hilfe mertens
besser gala stand in seiner sicht wie
dem auch sei das ist schon eine sehr
akribischer vergleich beide versionen
wenn eva reichl mertens drin steht hat
man sozusagen klassischen post sound
gehen wir alle kennen
aber dann ist beispielsweise michael
kleeberg den ich ganz am anfang mal
erwähnte hat mal angefangen die
recherche zu übersetzen ist jetzt über
den ersten band nicht hinausgekommen
aber das ist ein anderer post nicht weil
da was anderes erzählt würde sondern
weil ein klarer modernere ton darin
herrscht ich gebe zu ich bin damit nicht
glücklich geworden aber ich kenne viele
leute die recht angetan sind ich war
wahrscheinlich zu geprägt von der alten
übersetzung und dann gibt es ein
komplettes neues projekt komplette neue
übersetzung die vor 23 jahren bei
reklame schlossen worden ist von einem
herrn fischer glaubt bernd joachim mit
vornamen wie dem auch sei das ist ein
großartiger übersetzer und zwar insofern
besonders bemerkenswert als er gar nicht
aus der klassischen romanistik oder so
etwas kommt sondern einfach nur
begeisterung für die literatur hat
gleichzeitig mathematischen
informationstechnologische sein geld
verdient hat und darum mit einem
ganz akribisch genauen blick an die
übersetzungs aufgabe herangegangen ist
das liest sich sehr gut das ließ die
schlacken los was bei proust schon
einiges heißen wilden und bildet
trotzdem ziemlich genau die die die
satzstrukturen von bruce nach mehr als
bei rechel mertens wie ich finde ich bin
immer noch konventionell und
wahrscheinlich auch nostalgisch gestimmt
durch meine liebe zu erhalten
übersetzung aber fischers sachen haben
mir sehr gut gefallen und ich habe ihn
zwei drei mal getroffen und es war jedes
mal interessant sich von ihm dinge
erzählen zu lassen wie man mit
bestimmten sachen darum zu gehen hat und
darüber hinaus hat er sich mit der
recherche nicht begnügt sondern gibt
seit dem einbruch buch nach dem anderen
heraus hat einen fantastischen
briefwechsel zwischen marcel proust und
rinaldo an einem seiner engsten freunde
übersetzt sodass wir jetzt endlich mal
diesen briefwechsel so weiter erhalten
ist komplett auf deutsch haben nochmal
500 seiten und jetzt gerade hat er ein
extrem hilfreiches proust album
herausgebracht wo einfach nur die
wichtigsten figuren um masse brust herum
also aus seinem leben in bild und kurzen
texten und vor allem originalquellen die
dann auch wieder fischer übersetzt hat
vorgestellt werden das ist ein kleines
war der weg um mit dem mann
ausgesprochen viel spaß hat wenn man es
komplett liest dass man aber auch immer
wieder zum nachschlagen benutzen kann
wenn es um schnelle einordnungen von
figuren aus dem unmittelbaren umkreis
geht und das ist einfach angenehmer zu
betrachten und auch angenehmer zu lesen
als das großartige post lexikon was nur
scanner vor ein paar jahren
herausgebracht hat eine quelle des
wissens aber keine quelle des
uneingeschränkten lesevergnügen
das nennt man dann nicht auch noch mit
in den urlaub
dafür ist es zu schwer also man sieben
bände proust dabei hat dann will man
nicht auch noch dieses dicke schwere
kenner lexikon dabei haben das glaube
ich gerne das glaube ich gern sie haben
gerade gesagt dass die franzosen oder
die französische leserschaft proust in
seiner modernität zunächst nicht
verstanden hat wann hat sich das
geändert und können wir heute sicher
sein dass wir proust verstehen
nein man kann ja nie sicher sein ob man
literatur wirklich versteht es wäre
vermessen wenn wir das behaupten würden
wo es selber hat vollkommen zu recht
gesagt es gibt überhaupt keine leser
eines autors sondern es gibt nur leute
die in der lektüre von büchern sich
selbst suchen und sich selbst darin auch
ein
das heißt jeder von uns geht mit einer
anderen erwartungshaltung an bücher
heran und versucht darin die dinge
herauszufiltern und das begeistert uns
die etwas mit uns unmittelbar zu tun
haben die unserer weltanschauung
entsprechen in denen wir uns
wiederfinden und dementsprechend ist
jede lektüre eine absolut subjektive und
die verallgemeinerung die die
literaturwissenschaft betreibt ist in
meinen augen vermessen aber natürlich
hochinteressant weil mich die anderen
individuellen aspekte auch im leben viel
mehr interessieren hat mein eigener
blick auf die welt den kenn ich ja ich
möchte da gerade oder die andere
menschen die welt sehen und darum lesen
wir natürlich auch wiederum und wie dem
auch sei in frankreich war es so dass
einige der wirklich allerbesten
literatur protagonisten von trust seiten
aller bekannteste ist ganz sicher andré
gide mit der recherche am anfang
überhaupt nichts anfangen konnten poster
dieses buch an mehrere verlage geschickt
vor allem an die prominentesten und die
haben alle abgelehnt und im ende film
hat er den ersten band auf eigene kosten
bei einem kleinen verlag finanziert und
rita angeblich das ding abgelehnt ohne
überhaupt das manuskript geöffnet zu
haben
das hat sie zwar später immer bestritten
und er ist auch ganz schnell vom saulus
zum paulus geworden denn vier jahre
später ist er froh ist geradezu auf die
pelle gerückt um das buch wieder zu
seinem verlag rüberzuziehen was ihm dann
auch geglückt ist aber daran sieht man
wie schwer ist es letztlich hatte und
witzigerweise nicht der modernität wegen
sondern soweit ich es aus den
korrespondenzen aus den aufzeichnungen
von leuten der damaligen zeit kenne sind
die post insofern auf den leim gegangen
weil gerade der erste band vor allem im
neunzehnten jahrhundert spielt und zwar
in den 70er jahren zu wichtigen teilen
das heißt wir reden über ein buch was
über eine zeit erzählte die zum
zeitpunkt der publikation 40 jahre
zurücklag und darum wurde bewusst viel
mehr als traditionalist betrachtet denn
als erneuerer und das war ein problem
und das hat sich erst nach dem ersten
weltkrieg verändert er wurde dann immer
bekannter immer beliebter und nachdem er
gestorben ist war es geradezu
heiligsprechungen also ich sage ab 1922
war bewusst ganz klar der große autor
frankreich fürs zwanzigste jahrhundert
und daran hat sich bis heute nichts
geändert und werden wir jetzt im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert ungefähr
wissen welche übersetzung wir lesen
wollen nicht tendiere jetzt nach ihrer
beschreibung zu reklamieren auch das
warum warum soll ich 7000 seiten
weltsicht eines franzosen
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts anfang
des 20 warum sollte ich mir das antun
im urlaub wenn sie 7000 lesen dann lesen
sie beide übersetzungen das ja das
schöne daran sie sind ja schon mit
dreieinhalbtausend dabei ja es ist im
endeffekt nur halb so schlimm
nein man liest es deshalb weil man sich
in gewisser weise genau wie sie es
gerade sagen in diese weltsicht
versetzen lassen kann mit einem
unglaublichen erzählt witz den auf den
muss man erst mal stoßen ist das problem
sind die langen absätze bei proust auch
die langen sätze man muss sich in diese
sprache ein bisschen hineinwachsen aber
es gibt in meinen augen weniger autoren
die mit einer so wunderbaren ironie
erzählt haben die auch so herrlich
diskreditieren und über andere figuren
schreiben können und durchaus auch über
sich selbst also der erzähler der
recherche ist weiß gott nicht jemand der
einem unbedingt sympathisch sein muss
oder der wahnsinn ich konsequent
handelte sondern denkst mit genauso
vielen makeln und und nachlässigkeiten
behaftet wie so ziemlich alle anderen
figuren drin und sie bekommen
gleichzeitig ein fantastisches zeit
porträt und zwar eines was ich nicht
darin erschöpft dass paris waren
ungefähr 20 30 jahre neben rund um das
jäckle und bis über den ersten weltkrieg
hinaus vorzustellen sondern sie bekommen
auch eine mediengeschichte
beispielsweise was sie darin über
verlags praktiken der damaligen zeit
über die verbreitung von neuigkeiten
meine halbe über das was wir heute fake
news und ähnliche dinge nennen lesen
können das ist ganz grandios also es ist
vielleicht die beste kulturgeschichte
die man für diese zeit überhaupt geboten
bekommt und dass dann eben nicht auf
wissenschaftlicher art und weise unter
der ausnutzung unfassbar fehlerquellen
und gelehrsamkeit sondern in einem
erzählten ganz großartig witzigen stil
und diese verbindung von einer großen
romanhandlung wo man einfach oder ich
zumindest wissen will was passiert denn
mit diesem erzähler und mit vielen
anderen figuren die einem wirklich ans
herz wachsen und gleichzeitig verbunden
mit dieser immensen wissensvermittlung
über dieses frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhundert das ist etwas was ich so
bislang noch in keinem anderen buch
gefunden habe es gibt immer wieder
ansätze es gibt immer wieder die
vergleiche tolstoi wird natürlich sehr
gerne genannt mit krieg und frieden
natürlich wird thomas mann mit dem
zauberberg genannt und ähnliche kaliber
der internationalen literatur aber in
der kombination eben wirklich dieses
fantastischen humors dieser glorreichen
sprache und dieses universalen ansatzes
würde ich sagen steht proust
alleine ich will nicht behaupten dass es
nirgendwo in der weltliteratur etwas
vergleichbares gibt aber ich hab's noch
nicht gefunden andrea diener hat er
jetzt ganz zu anfang von madeleines und
lindenblütentee gesprochen als den
beiden stichwörtern die ihr zur post ein
fein haben sie auch solche stichwörter
nicht mehr am anfang hatte ich natürlich
ganz genau die gleichen dass madeleine
erlebnis also dieses durch den geschmack
aufsteigende erinnerungsvermögen
früheste vergangenheit als kind oder
sowas ist natürlich etwas was jedem von
uns gerade in olfaktorischen also
geruchs phänomenen sofort evident
erscheint nun doch jeder von uns hat es
schon mal erlebt aber vor kurzer zeit
noch niemand so beschrieben
wenn es ansonsten hängt bei mir eher an
an orten und annahmen das ist natürlich
auch genau das was bei proust ganz
wichtig ist er evoziert viel mehr dinge
über den kontakt mit dingen sachen die
er sieht leute die er sieht orte die er
sieht da kommen dann die die großen
kathedralen besichtigungen die in der
recherche stattfinden wo die alten
portale gewürdigt werden auch in dem was
sie für die moderne bedeuten da kommen
die wunderbaren seebäder in der
normandie
da kommen figuren wie der ballon war und
chalets der aus einer sehr skurrilen
figur später zu einer abgründigen figur
wird unter die fantastischen
frauenfiguren in der recherche wie
beispielsweise oder es waren eine
kokotte die aber zu einer wahnsinnig
geschickten manipulateure in der männer
wird und die der erzähler vergöttert
ohne sie jemals ohne jemals wirklich
nahe zu kommen und trotzdem versteht
dieses buch diese frau also das ist für
mich das was ich so unglaublich daran
finde diese wirklich tief empfundene
psychologie dieses hineindenken auch
noch in die unangenehmsten figuren die
es da gibt und ich kenne keine wirklich
richtig fiese figur in der recherche an
uns alle selbst die leute die erkennbar
auch post nicht geschätzt hat in seinem
eigenen figuren repertoire irgendwo
dadurch sympathisch werden dass sie so
großartig beobachtet sind dass man sagt
also wenn der jetzt weg wäre dann würde
ein riesen baustein aus diesem
fantastischen literatur kathedralen bau
wegbrechen und dementsprechend mag man
sie alle
die waren ja ich weiß nicht ist hier
geht aber ich bin jetzt kurz
vor sonderurlaub zu beachten
und ja ja ja doch schon ehrlich gesagt
ich bin ich bin in trägt wie man so
schön sagt ja wir machen dann einfach in
einem halben jahr einen podcast und dann
frage ich nach ihren erfahrungen für
mich ein kleines bisschen unter druck
aber gut ein ja und das sind ja auch nur
3500 und 7000 seiten wie erleichternd ja
genau vielen vielen dank für dieses
wunderbare gespräch ich hoffe auch
unsere leser und hörer haben ein
bisschen lust bekommen da hinein zu
schmecken ich habe es auf jeden fall
wir schreiben auf jeden fall alle
biografischen angaben zu den erwähnten
werken den biographien in die show notes
bzw auf die website und da können sie
das alles dann in ruhe nachlesen also
nicht zurückspulen und mitschreiben
müssen sie alles gar nicht beschreiben
es auf vielen dank ebay platzt aus
ich danke ihnen für diese tolle
möglichkeit über jemand zu reden da wär
echt was bedeutet das hat man gemerkt
man kann die schriftstellerin nawar
ibrahimi durch die zwei romane kennen
die sie bereits veröffentlicht hat durch
16 wörter 2017 und das paradies meines
nachbarn aus dem jahr 2020
man sollte sie kennen wenn man sich für
literatur interessiert weil sie gerade
erst den bachmann preis gewonnen hat mit
ihrer erzählung der cousin einem das
stand so bei uns in der faz zumindest zu
lesen selbstreflexiven verspielten text
der von der frage handelt wie sich
traumatische lebenserfahrungen in einem
zur heimat geworden exil vermitteln
lassen
das kann ich als bachmannpreis ultra und
jedes jahr fernseh schlachtenbummler
eigentlich auch nur bestätigen ein sehr
komplexer text nach dem preis wird man
auch erfahrungsgemäß einmal durch ganz
österreich gereicht und mit etwas glück
liegt das hinterland ibrahimi und ich
hatte jetzt gelegenheit ihr unsere
üblichen drei fragen zum schreiben und
lesen und leben zu stellen und als
erstes die warum sie schreibt ich
schreibe aus mehreren gründen glaube ich
aber ein grund ist auf jeden fall dass
ich gerne gestalte und schreiben ist
glaube ich meine art zu gestalten ich
mag auch die macht die ich dann in
gewissem sinne habe war meine figuren
und ich glaube es ist auch mein weg mit
den ganzen widersprüchlichkeiten und
ambivalenzen die das leben so hat fertig
zu werden
wer ist ihr erster leser oder ihre erste
leserin und wie kritisch darf er oder
sie seien
das ist sehr unterschiedlich also oft
ist mein mann mein erster leser manchmal
sind das aber auch freunde die die
selbst aufschreiben und seltener ehrmann
elektro renner dass ich meistens schon
jemand anders vorher drüber schauen ja
das ist immer so ein bisschen das
problem ich wünsche mir schon dass mein
erster leser meine erste leserin sehr
kritisch ist aber meistens da es ja
meistens irgendwie menschen sind die
mich kennen und die mir auch nachstehend
vertraue ich ihn nie ganz so also habe
ich dann 2 3 aus und hoffe dass dann im
gesamtbild wirklich eine kritische
rückmeldung entsteht welches buch würden
sie ihrem jüngeren ich empfehlen oder
gibt es ganz viele bücher die gerade
erscheint gut dass sie das sagen
gebracht so viele bücher die erscheinen
die ich so gerne mit 20 gelesen hätte
also sowas wie die drei also drei
kameraden oder auch von as st
da dann betrachtung einer bar in oder
auch doris lessing das goldene notizbuch
gut das ist schon ein bisschen älter
aber es gibt so viele bücher die ich
jetzt gerade in die finger kriege von
denen ich mir denke es war so toll
gewesen wenn ich das mit 20 schon
irgendwie alles gelesen hat oder auch
die die comic romane von livestrong
christa also beinahe also ich könnte die
liste jetzt unendlich fortsetzen also es
sind alles bücher die sich mit
feminismus beschäftigen und auch mit ja
ich meine dass die romane jetzt zum
beispiel die ich erwähnt habe die setzen
sich jetzt nicht bewusst mit dem einen
oder anderen thema auseinander aber da
werden schon dinge verhandelt die mich
auch sehr berührt haben 20 also sowas
wie rassismus oder auch einfach viele
themen und das hätte ich damals
eigentlich total gut brauchen können und
das ist vieles ist jetzt für mich eine
offenbarung
in den schoß und auf unserer seite
faz.net / bücher - podcast bücher mit de
finden sie einen gastbeitrag von nawal
ibrahimi über den westlichen blick den
sie sich angeeignet hat und das eigene
selbst das hat sich vor anderthalb
jahren für uns geschrieben
und natürlich finden sie dort auch jede
menge kost wer uns erreichen will der
kennt unsere e mail adresse bücher
podcast faz.de bücher mit louis wir uns
in den pott kitchen oder in den sozialen
medien licon oder abonnieren oder mit
sternchen versehen oder sonstiges will
der weiß ich ja auch wie das geht bei
instagram heißen wir etwas bücher in
einem wort und mit natürlich wir sagen
danke fürs zuhören und bis zum nächsten
mal
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]